今回は貧乏小学生歌との秘密に迫るよなぜ
金持から貧乏になってしまったのかみんな
見てみてねはいありがとうな
よバンカラジオ
[拍手]
ト行くよ
それすげえそれ
すげえ
[音楽]
それ次はワンピースカードで遊ぼういいね
ほやるよほほいほい
ほいほいどいえばさなんでゆトってそんな
に貧乏なの僕は本当はめちゃこ金持ちなん
よ何言ってんだか本当は貧乏なくせに嘘
つくなよ僕の名前は歌ゆうと実は3年前の
ことただいまなんよゆうとっちゃまお帰り
なさいませぽい僕の家はめちゃんこ金持ち
でお父さんはめちゃんこめちゃんこ大企業
の社長ですっごく厳しかったん
[音楽]
よどうぞだからいつもやめてって言ってる
んよ
スクバスク
ほですお金お金
ポポポポういよいよ
飯をしっかり食えお菓子ばっかり食ってん
じゃないんよあお父さんこないだ桃競争で
決めとったんよだから何なんよえっと俺は
なんだえっと今回はこれでも頑張った方な
ん
よ俺の息子なのにこれしかできないのかお
正気なんよ
[拍手]
あんたの教育が間違ってたんじゃない
ダイヤないよダイヤなんよお前を俺の金で
ダイヤばっかり買って返すんよ嫌なんよひ
おじなんなん
よもういいんよお前はこの家から出てくん
よこの失敗
すめもも
おちょっとあんたあいつは何もできない
どうせすぐ帰って
くるこうして僕の今の生活は始まったんよ
でもこの貧乏生活もなかなか悪くないんよ
負けたなんでユトのが強いんだよ頑張って
集めたんよゴミゴミゴミゴミフとビカワン
ピカワンピカこんな貧乏な生活でも何も不
自由なことはないし大好きな友達がいる
から僕は楽しく暮らせているん
よあみんな僕はモの練習があるから帰るん
よバイ
バイお父様からの命令です今すぐ家に戻っ
てくださいみんなと離れたくないんよ僕は
戻らんのよ早く帰るんよ
グッドモーニン
[音楽]
ご朝ご飯はリングない
[拍手]
よただ飯は最高なん
[音楽]
よの時間だお前ら好きな味でも書いてろは
たぜお金なくて買えなかったん
よゴムで
ポポポできたんよ
え給食の時間だいただきますいただき
ます私お腹いっぱいいるえいいの
ありがとう僕もこれあげる嫌いだから俺も
あげる僕のお金持からフレンチしか食べ
ないんだえ全部くれんの
ありがとう行け行け攻撃行け行け攻撃行け
けけけ行けおらおらはいこあはい俺の勝ち
すごい
よ言うと10円あげるから部屋の掃除して
くんないえ10もれんの
ありがとうぽいぽいぽい
こい
おあお母さん登場終わったから100円
ちょうだいはいやねちゃんありがとうやっ
たやねちゃみんちょっと外の水借りていい
いいよはいありがとうなよブブ
し儲かったしタブも入れるし最高だよ
お坊っちゃまみともないことはやめてお
戻りください嫌なんよ僕はみんなと一緒に
いたいんよですが僕は帰らないよ
[拍手]
見ともないもういい俺が行くんよお前ら
ついてこい
はいゴミあたりゴミありんつついに
スイッチは見つけたんよママママママ
[音楽]
お10円ないよあ
1010また
10また
1010円なよ10円なよあ10円なよ
10円が20枚もあるたのさスッチ1台
変えるんよ
え久しぶりだなその金はくれてやるだから
今すぐ俺の家へ帰ってくるん
よお父さんえ
お前どうしたんだお父さんが来るんよ怖い
よ分かったお前はそこに隠れ
てろ俺のユトを
出せ生徒が怖がっているためお帰り
ください俺は親だぞ生徒たちは私の子供
同然です子供を怖がらせる上は親とは言え
ない
教師としてのプライドだ私は
生徒必ず
[音楽]
守るこれでどう
だお父様こちら息子さんのゆ君ですよしゃ
師パチンコ
だお前は歌に戻るんだ
ばこの学校めちゃくちゃにするんよ早く
[音楽]
しようみんなには迷惑かけらんないん
よさようならなん
よ
うと本当にいいのか俺ら友達だろ
なんとか
言え助け
て当たり前
だ行く
ぞおあ僕はお金持ちだから家族とフレンチ
行って
[笑い]
[音楽]
くる助かると思ってんのか諦めるんよ小学
生ごがこの家に侵入することはできない
なぜなら執事が24時間張っていてお前の
鍵はお母さんが持ってるから
なだそうだ大体の情報は入手したすげえな
n僕天才ですから盗はけさせてもらってよ
俺の
出せ生徒がってためお帰りください俺は親
だぞキュートダカ作戦行くぞ
ラキートはプールの中に入って様子を
伺えもちろん青いから見つから
[音楽]
ない
ん四角から水うんちで羊を転ばせるんだ
よっしゃああああ無
[拍手]
[音楽]
すぎ冬だったからここやったかだがこれで
変装
できるよし変装
完了お母さんはダイヤが大ないよダイヤ
おもちゃのダイヤでお母さんを誘導して鍵
を盗み出す
ないよないよえ大きい大きいダイヤなん
よよし
よしダヤないよダヤない
よおダイヤないよダイヤないよダイヤない
よダイヤないよ熱いよきキラキラ
マメロうわ
[音楽]
助けに来たぞえ
誰ゆとこれで逃げられるぞ
やすありがとうなよれる
なそんなのお見通しなん
[音楽]
よもうお前
は終わりなんよ
それはどうか
なこのハミサイルは遡ること1日ユトが
落とした10円玉を利用してパチンコ1
時間ですちまった先生をやめちまったし何
なればいいん
だえ
[音楽]
だおじゃあミサイルになり
[拍手]
ましょうゆう
とありがとうなん
よイエー
逃げるぞ言うとありがとう屋根
ちみ俺の太のパワーには叶わないよもう
逃げられないよその友達から離れてうに
戻るん
よ絶対絶対嫌ないよ2度と戻らんのよ
こっちには美味しい食事も大きな家もある
何が不満なん
よそこ
にそこに愛はない
よ間に合った
か僕の家お金持ちだからヘで迎えにったよ
場所はここだ助けに来てくれご飯食べたら
ねごちさでしたあお父様同助てたくてヘリ
りてもいいかな追いましょう我々はヘリを
早く行きましょう早く旦那様
早くか
[拍手]
しっかしさあんなお金持ちの家僕だったら
買えるけどねいいよ貧乏でもこの最高な
友達がいるから僕は幸せなん
[拍手]
よでかダヤなよでかダヤなよゆうと
なかなかやるじゃないかあいつもいい友達
を持ったもんだな俺も家族と向き合わない
となおいお前ちょっと2人で旅行でも行く
かはなんなんよ急に気持ち悪いんよでかだ
ヤないよでかだまだまだ時間かかりそうだ
なかないなかないよ
な
えななんなんよこれマママ
マゆうと今まで住まなかったプレゼントだ
あお父さん
ん早く帰ってこい帰ってくるならその
プレゼントもらってもいいぞあ最悪ない
よちゃちゃチャンネル登録チャンネル登録
チャンネル登録よろしくチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
最初はグン録じゃんけん
登録チャンネル登録